Oh
if you were like me spinning around in a
circle for just a few seconds is enough
to render you uncomfortably dizzy now
imagine if you had to spend every second
of every day spinning at a rate of 460
meters per second or roughly 1,000 miles
per hour well provided you're standing
near the equator you kind of already do
the earth makes one full rotation every
23 hours and 56 minutes and it's
circumference is roughly 40,000 75
kilometers which gives the surface of
our home planet a rotational speed of
416 meters per second around the equator
besides giving us what we know as our
day and night cycle the planets rotation
has profound effect on the conditions of
Earth what would happen if that rotation
suddenly stopped if we assume that some
unknown force stopped the earth
instantly the immediate effect would be
disastrous
the effect would be similar to what
you'd experience if you hit an immovable
barrier on the highway while not wearing
a seat belt except instead of traveling
at 70 miles an hour you'd be going a
thousand miles an hour the earth itself
would stop spinning but the atmosphere
liquids and most objects around the
world would be launched sideways at 460
meters per second buildings would be
leveled by winds exceeding the speed of
atomic blast shockwaves humans animals
and cars would become billions of
individual ballistic missiles the
momentum and sudden lack of gravity near
the equator would create enormous
kilometers high tsunamis that could
sweep across land masses in a matter of
minutes as the world's oceans rush
towards the poles any area is lucky
enough to survive the destructive winds
and massive tsunamis would likely be
stripped bare by more gradual erosion
from continued winds destroying animal
habitats homes and farmland the world
would suffer from massive droughts and
with most or all of the water gone or
far away there would be no way to
support life for an extended period of
time the immediate aftermath of this
planetary braking is severe and would
likely put every species on earth
including humans on the critically
endangered list if not extinct
altogether but what about the long-term
effect of an on spinning earth there
would be many less destructive effects
to the change and some serious ones that
might not be obvious at first
for example days would last much much
longer right now it takes the earth
about 24 hours to
spin on its axis marking one full day if
the planet stopped spinning gradually
say over the course of several billion
years it would eventually reach a point
where it would be considered
sun-synchronous meaning one rotation of
the earth would take 365 days similar to
tidal locking this state would cause
every spot on earth to exist in
permanent day or permanent night the
oceans would boil or evaporate entirely
on the day side of the planet and freeze
on the night side making life
exceptionally difficult if not
impossible except in the slim Twilight
regions between the day and night sides
if instead the earth reached a point
where it had stopped spinning entirely
you would experience half a year of
sunlight and half a year of darkness
which might allow for slightly more
livable conditions but would likely ruin
agriculture and plant growth cycles as
there would be no real transition
between seasons one very gradual change
would be the planets change from its
current globe shape to a more perfect
sphere right now due to the Earth's
rotation there is a slight bulge around
the equator making the earth more of a
deflated ball than a sphere because of
this bulge the area around the equator
holds more of the world's ocean water as
the earth shifted towards a more
spherical shape this water would flood
surrounding areas as it migrates towards
the poles where gravity is the strongest
this would create two enormous polar
oceans and leave one giant continent
that would wrap around the equator if
you lived in this polar ocean world you
could walk around the entire earth
without ever having to cross a body of
water
another gradual but more lethal change
would be the slow dissipation of the
Earth's magnetic field when the planet
spins molten metal from the core Rises
cools and sinks back down creating
convection currents and generating
magnetic energy if the earth stopped
spinning this process would grind to a
halt and the planet's magnetic field
would fade away leaving the surface to
be bombarded with cosmic radiation and
lethal rays from the Sun years of
constant baking from radiation would
render the earth rocky and lifeless much
like our sister planet Mars which once
had a magnetosphere of its own when Mars
lost its magnetic field the Sun slowly
stripped away the planet's atmosphere
scorching the surface and leaving the
barren red planet we know today so the
Earth's rotation is really the only
thing standing between us and planet
why disaster luckily there's not really
any chance of that spin suddenly coming
to a halt sure the planet will slowly
stop spinning but it'll be over the
course of billions of years and humanity
will most likely be extinct or long gone
by then and as far as we know there's
nothing that could stop the Earth's
rotation immediately with the exception
of maybe another planet colliding with
ours but in that case we'd be dead
either way make sure to check out my
other space related videos by clicking
this playlist or if you're really bored
you can watch all my videos by clicking
here remember to subscribe to keep up to
date with the latest content and leave a
comment down below with your thoughts on
today's topic you can also check out my
new combined Instagram with real life
lore where we share photos of our
adventures and daily life thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video